you know who we are a sentence
immediately contradicted by making us
sit through another previously on you're
in die you know all signals in or out
are blocked the well-traveled and
experienced jedi knight does not already
know this considering obi-wan should be
trying to keep a low profile i find his
choice of slightly dusty jedi knight
disguise disturbing i absolutely love
this shot and think everyone involved in
the production design of this show
deserves a ton of praise but if you do
an image search on the interwebs for
sci-fi city about 90 of the results look
something like this so despite my
personal feelings i must award the
appropriate number of sins for a sci-fi
cityscape looks like an urban neon dream
cliche also there may actually be a good
chance this was pulled from google
images since this sign here is turned on
its side and repeated here and then this
sign here seems to be a mirror image of
this sign here and don't tell me it
doesn't matter and that i'm the only one
lame enough to pay attention to this
because that just might be true and i am
not ready to reassess how i'm spending
my life
okay the fact that this retired clone
trooper is played by tamira morrison is
a very nice touch what i can say nice
things and trust me for all its
aspirations this show will not be
choking on sin removals break it up
there are like three people here i see
nothing to break up nor any obstructions
requiring the creation of said path i
got a castle pure oh man i hear kessel
will get you [ __ ] up for like 12
parsecs i'm looking for my daughter
directing this question to a spice
dealer only makes sense if leia's into
underground raves listen i get that the
star wars franchise revolves around one
family in the same like 10 people but
that doesn't excuse obi-wan from
thinking that every criminal knows about
all the types of crime
of course this overly dramatic
de-hooding is entirely for the
audience's benefit but why is he
revealing his face at all even if he's
just pretending to be a jedi robin hood
wouldn't he want to mask his identity as
much as possible just in case these
lovely people are caught and
interrogated this is a jedi mind trick
do not be alarmed
i'm inside your mind this is one of the
few times i wish disney actually would
get inside my mind so they could hear me
screaming stop wasting kumail nanjiani i
am hajistri
jedi
i help all who are in need in return i
ask only a few credits this must be the
riskiest [ __ ] hustle to ever hustle
what this scheme boils down to is kumail
non-jediyani here taking money from
vulnerable people to secure them illegal
passage off world so is painting a force
shaped target on the back of this scheme
while there's an active jedi hunt going
on the safest way to do business you're
a bottom feeder
a rat who preys on weakness one of my
biggest gripes with star wars that some
things get fun fanciful names like
jack-o-beast and other times the writers
should settle for things we have on
earth like rats and don't give me some
rationalization about rats being some
kind of immutable universal constant
because i'll just start giving out sins
for everyone speaking english if it's
the sewage you want there's only one
place to go
but you'll never get it astr has
obviously never tried walking in what
are you doing back here darth maul cop i
know the whole point is that obi-wan is
out of practice and not quite in tune
with the force anymore but it just feels
super jarring to see a jedi in a
fistfight and i swear if a show called
kenobi takes more than three episodes to
actually kenobi i i
well i guess i'll just have to re-watch
the prequels see what you did disney
stop making me like things that i enjoy
hating
i love this little detail of obi-wan
hurting his hand when he slaps the
zebrakian on his horns but why is he
slapping someone this high up on their
head to begin with i'm surprised you
fell for it flea would be excellent at
tv sins which is just a bizarre sentence
all around inquisitor
really figured you out bad guy exposes
plot information to the protagonist
because he's a staunch supporter of
education and yes when the character
motivations are thin i'm just gonna have
my own details where is the girl
she must be close doesn't matter you're
not getting out of here but kenobi will
of course get out of here because rather
than tie him it's much more fun to
mox-posit just long enough for him to
come up with a way to escape well
everybody believes all these fools let
him reach into his pockets hold this jar
of spice in front of their faces and
deliver this line because the script
told them their plan was foiled and they
were to do nothing about it thinking any
bounty is more important than finishing
your barbecue and that i'm not ready and
willing to sin every single time a
series has a character leave their meal
completely untouched yeah put this on
can i try this one instead of the city
is looking for you you don't need those
and the gloves
kids seriously this could be the most
kids worthy scene in the entire history
of television and i've seen stranger
things don't smell anything don't look
at anything
don't touch anything the kindergarten
jedi portion of the episode goes on for
all the unoriginal who the [ __ ] asked
for this amount of some time i read that
jedi can make things float make me float
what i want to float foreshadowing i let
your parents know you're safe so we're
just going to forget about the whole
you're in die you know all signals in or
out are blocked can't even blame it on
the plot because obi-wan updating leia's
parents doesn't really change a damn
thing look it's one thing to not be
consistent with the wider star wars
universe but to contradict yourself
inside your own 30-minute episode is
downright impressive that's what you
were hiding you're the reason i'm here
they took me to get to you my goodness
in the name of yoda the jedi and
qui-gon's force goes was that a leap why
wouldn't leia just assume that they'd
been spotted escaping and that's why his
face was everywhere how'd she manage to
immediately jump to the plot synopsis
this is the second time in the series
that leis eluded an adult using this
unimpressive running pace it's like the
show wants us to believe that a long
time ago in a galaxy far far away knees
didn't evolve in a way that allowed
grownups to use the maximum length of
their stride
this gorn trooper inexplicably does stop
long enough to allow leia to get out of
the way and then also manages to miss
obi-wan despite him being in wide open
air this rooftop running sequence was
actually pretty cool the only thing
cooler would have been if the riders let
riva actually catch up to obi-wan during
the chase so that all the gratuitous
parkouring could have been relevant to
the story dual wielding blasters but
only shooting one at a time also
shooting your dual blasters in two very
different directions when your target is
remaining in the same spot i'm not gonna
stand here and say this doesn't look
cool but i will stand here and ask why
it was any better than just jumping over
the damn thing
none of the four stormtroopers or dozens
of passing people break a stride after
this very loud pew pew and the resulting
noise made by these six feet of
stumbling metal since i met you i've
been chased shot at i almost fell to my
death and now there are inquisiting
people after us
if somebody is offering us help i think
we should take it most of this happened
because of her unwillingness to trust
obi-wan who was also offering help at
the time so the sin is the bin season
instead of misguided optimism was your
friend a jedi too
no she was a leader leia's entire
character being built off of who she
will become and who padme was may be in
line with all the themes of destiny
running through star wars but it also
eliminates pretty much any stakes for
her story
yes here we go okay i suppose two
episodes isn't too long to wait to see
obi-wan rock that blue stick of jedi
justice let's go
watch and learn
stabbing your gi in his gi
writers think this is a good enough
explanation for why obi-wan couldn't
catch leia earlier in the episode
since the time and place of said
destruction are already known to most
viewers this threat carries very little
weight and if this is news to you go
watch the original trilogy of heathen
the look on my face after realizing this
season will not be an original story but
mostly tie-ins to the original trilogy
somehow makes it into the episode
look mock all you want but no one wears
seven layers of cosmetic alterations
like hayden christensen and there is no
one else in the entire world that would
have been able to play the parts of
vader that matter most but also don't
require james earl jones
i will look for you i will find you
and i will kill you a new life awaits
you in the off-world column
oh hello
i know right
whose balls did i have to fondle to get
my very own movie i'm looking for my
daughter as she was taken and she's on
this planet
[Music]
magic
the shadows are my ram for the light
it's an unforgiving place for my kind
everything that guy just says [ __ ]
who are you i'm batman
this guy's not having a good time he's
going to feel terrible tomorrow morning
because there's some things in this
world that are just wrong okay and
stealing a princess is one of them
[Music]
don't let go i'll never let go
you choo-choo choose me
oh no he died